mariners a chance for the brief
two-game series sweep to bring
themselves within a game of the a's if
they can pull out another victory by the
bay there's cole irwin on the mound
today for the oakland a's his 25th start
j.p crawford getting set to lead things
off the mariners today
the opposite way and a base hit off the
bat at jp crawford got ahead of the
count and stings it to left field for a
lead-off single
this one is popped up
that's harrison the second baseman going
out
let's everybody know he's got it
shallow right field
of coming in and kenneth has it for the
second half
high papa
right side to the diamond looks like
josh harrison is there
and he's got it up on the mound for the
mariners chris flexon mike coming off
back-to-back quality starts
lace right to france boy right place
right time
wanna know to starling marte
and that one is gonna get by france
in the right field so marte slaps the
single the other way
here's olson deep in the box an open
stance
not going and that one's cued
into center field for a hit
here's mitch moreland
that one has bounced and that's good to
get through in the shallow left field
marte is gonna score easily
and it's one nothing a so mitch moreland
just hit it the other way he hit it
right where nobody was
and the a's will take it one nothing
[Music]
and he got him
first strike out of the day for chris
flex and he strands a pair a's leading
after one
lead off man retired for luis terrence
hard hit stung out towards the gap in
left center field kemp can't get to it
terence is on his way to second
he's got himself a one out stand up
double
one out one on for tom murphy
into left field past the dive of andrews
terence is into third
kemp in with the ball quickly
now the mariners have the time run on it
third and here's center fielder jared
kelneck
on the first pitch into right field
terrence scores countercast tied this
game
murphy into second we're even at one
rbi base hit by jared kellnick
scooped on the short hop by elvis anders
he throws across in time run on three
hits for seattle
seeger batting with the shift on two
outs
this is past harrison's dive through the
shift
seeger two-ounce single montoro trying
to extend his hitting streak to seven
ball games
stung into the corner canna can't get to
it fairball
seeger is on his way to third he's being
held there toro tiptoes into second base
with a double police terrence
be the hitter
seeger the go ahead and run
lined into right field terence a
multi-hit day he scores seeger from
third base toro's coming around he
scores from second terrence drives in a
pair and it's 3-1 mariners with two outs
of the third inning
one hop nice big bounce for harrison and
that will do it
that is cole irvin and he is headed back
to the clubhouse so the new pitcher is
deolis guerra when
two two pitch that's a swing in the miss
crawford strikes out that's the first
strikeout for an ace pitcher today
[Applause]
that time he swings and misses so a
couple of strikeouts for deoliskera
bottom of the fourth coming up chappie
struck out his first time up
looked like he caught him right in the
wrist
oh yeah left wrist
chapman says he's all right that's good
news
right to kyle seeger at third base
chapman stranded after four mariners by
two the o2 ready now gareth rose it's
swung on in myth
he goes
fastball up top 91 just
come and get it
toro drives one
toward marte marte hustling back deep
center field and he's got it
knocked down by guerra
picks it up
throws wall moreland digs it out
strike three call murphy knew it
that's four strikeouts for deolas guerra
[Applause]
five strikeouts in three innings of work
puck takes over his seventh appearance
and crawford waves at that pitch
he definitely went there and that's
another strikeout
back-to-back strikeouts for puck
shoots this into right field for a base
hit picks a funny bounce on canna
doesn't do any damage though france is
aboard why wouldn't he
works and base hit off a puck
chapman hustling over
into foul territory and chapman grabs it
it's number 11 to murphy
dots them up lower outside corner flexon
gets out number two in his fifth punch
out of the day
if elvis andrews is able to work
his way on base
this could very well be an opportunity
for these to chip away here and get
themselves back into this ball game
line drive fair
down the left field line and alva
sanders is going to have a two out
double
inherits two men with two out
going after the first pitch
popped up shallow right toro out haniger
in one pitch out number three
and the eights strand two
tip that's the swing in the base
strike three call
friends
could not pull the trigger
four strikeouts for puck
murphy stings this to the gap
tom murphy on base for the third time
this will be a tough a b for kalnick
rifles this out to right field short
hops the wall
murphy is into third he's coming home
kelnick smokes a ribby double and the
mariners tack on an insurance run it's
four to one of the eighth inning
dylan moore now looking for his first
base hit up the afternoon
delamore past the dive of elvis andrews
kellnick
is on his way home
dylan moore tacks on another it's a 5-1
mariners lead with two outs in the
eighth and there he goes and the ball is
hit into shallow center
marte coming in
and he's got
two runs on three hits for the mariners
that one is a base hit right over stefan
ryder's head
crawford
toro onto first not in time
scott wants to see if they should
challenge this it's pretty close it is
let's find out
out at first base
how
[Applause]
[Music]
on this one goes into a slot and he
caught it nice play by starlight marty
he was
just shaded slightly into right center
field and because of that he was able to
get there
out number one chapman whips
tony kemp
first pitch in play koelnik
battling the sun two outs
murphy hits it fair
seeger dove to the backhand could not
get it the ball rolls and comes to a
stop near the bullpen and murphy has a
two out double
and plain to jp crawford on to first and
the mariners sweep aside the a's in two
games for now a season best 11 games
over 500 and the mariners are within one
of oakland and the wild card hunt